The year of the Batman reveals continues.
The first trailer for the second season of
the DC Universe series Titans has been released,
and it gives fans their first look at Iain
Glen's Bruce Wayne and, as an added bonus,
Esai Morales' Deathstroke, canonically the
Titans' most persistent nemesis.
Titans is the inaugural original series effort
for DC Universe, and its first season racked
up accolades for its dark yet humorous take
on the Teen Titans, DC's classic superhero
team led by Dick Grayson, better known as
Robin.
"F--- Batman."
During the first season, the rest of the team
included Rachel Roth, or Raven, the alien
Koriand'r, a.k.a. Starfire, and Gar Logan,
otherwise known as Beast Boy.
The group also crossed paths with Donna Troy,
also known as Wonder Girl, Hank Hall, a.k.a.
Hawk, and Dawn Granger, a.k.a. Dove, all of
whom can be spotted briefly in the trailer
for season 2.
Fans had an inkling that Bruce Wayne would
be a part of this new season; at the conclusion
of season 1, Robin endured an episode-long
hallucination in which he, five years in the
future, was forced to track down and kill
an out-of-control Batman.
The elaborate hallucination was an effort
on the part of the demon Trigon, Rachel's
father, to take control of Grayson's mortal
form.
It's a goal he seems to accomplish at the
season's end but we'll have to wait and see
how that plays out.
Fans had been psyched to catch a glimpse of
Glen as Wayne, and we got one, however brief.
Well, we can report that he looks the part,
although we're not so sure that he exactly
sounds like the Dark Knight.
"See you made the news with your old Titans
friends… new ones too."
Glen is Scottish, and we're sure that in his
mind, he's doing a flawless American accent
but to American ears, it sounds a little bit
dodgy.
Aside from Wayne, the spot also introduces
viewers to Drew Van Acker's Aqualad and Chelsea
T. Zhang's Ravager and, at its conclusion,
Deathstroke, standing bathed in shadow at
the end of a dark, foreboding hallway.
Obviously, we don't get a good look at the
villain's costume, but he sure cuts a badass,
menacing figure, and we're sure that's not
the only thing he'll be cutting; he didn't
bring along those swords for nothing.
Also, in a moment fans have been waiting for
since it was teased in the post-credits stinger
of the season 1 finale, we get a look at Joshua
Orpin's Superboy, and Krypto, the Super-Dog.
We don't get to see the pooch in action, but
we're thinking that the show's producers didn't
want to tip their hand too soon.
Will he be wearing a cape when he bounds into
action?
That would really be the icing on the cake.
If, like us, you're a big fan of the Dark
Knight, this year has been and will continue
to be a very good one in terms of giving us
more live-action Batmen than you can shake
a Batarang at.
First, the series finale of Gotham finally
gave us that show's version of the Caped Crusader,
something we'd all been anticipating for the
entirety of the show's run.
September will see the premiere of Titans'
second season, and in December, the CW's Arrowverse
will stage another of its huge crossover events,
one with a name that every single DC fan will
recognize: "Crisis on Infinite Earths."
Cast in the role of Bruce Wayne for the multiverse
mashup: Kevin Conroy, who has provided the
voice of the character in animated series,
features, and video games for over two decades.
Many Bat-fans, in fact, believe his interpretation
of Bruce Wayne to be the definitive one, and
you'll get no argument from us.
DC Universe made serious waves with its cancellation
of Swamp Thing after only one episode of its
truncated first season had aired, but any
rumblings that the service may be in danger
of folding have seemingly been put to rest,
with Doom Patrol recently renewed for a second
season, an amazingly not-safe-for-work trailer
for the animated Harley Quinn series, and
now, our first look at what appears to be
a smashing new season for Titans.
We'll keep our ears to the ground for any
news concerning the streamer's slate of original
series, and keep you up to speed.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.